so as a child I used to spend all of my
time at my great grandmother's house on
hot humid summer days I would dash
across the floor and stick my face in
front of her only air conditioner but I
didn't realize that that simple
experience though brief was a privileged
one in our community growing up stories
of next-door neighbors having to set up
fake energy accounts or having to steal
energy seemed normal to me during the
winters struggling to get warm my
neighbors would have no choice with the
bypass déméter after their heat was shut
off just to keep their family
comfortable for one more day these kinds
of dangerous incidents can take root
when people are faced with impossible
choices in the u.s. the average American
spends 3 percent of their income on
energy
in contrast low-income and rural
populations can spend 20 even 30 percent
of their income on energy in 2015 this
caused over 25 million people to skip
meals to variety hour to their homes
this is when energy becomes a burden but
energy burdens are so much more than
just a number they present impossible in
perilous choices do you take your child
to get her flu medicine or do you feed
her or do you keep her warm it's an
impossible choice in nearly every mosque
7 million people choose between medicine
and energy this exposes a much larger
and systemic issue families with high
energy burdens are disproportionately
people of color who spend more per
square foot than their white
counterparts but it's also nurses
veterans and even schoolteachers who
fall into the mass of 37 million people
a year who are unable to afford energy
for their most basic needs as a result
those who have high energy burdens have
a greater likelihood of conditions like
heart disease and as
my look given our rockets to Mars in our
pocket-sized AI we have the tools to
address these systemic inequities the
technology is here cost of renewables
insulation micro grids and smart home
technology are all decreasing however
even as we approach cost parity the
majority of those who own solar earn
much more than the average American this
is why when I was 22 I founded the
nonprofit ready our mission is to
alleviate energy burdens by working with
communities utilities and government
agencies alike to provide equitable
access to clean energy energy efficiency
and energy technology but there is no
one way to solve this I believe in the
power of local communities in the
transforming effect of relationships so
we start by working directly with the
communities that have the highest energy
burdens we host workshops and events for
communities to learn about energy
poverty and how by making even small
updates to their homes like better
insulation for windows and water heaters
can go a long way to maximize efficiency
we're connecting neighborhoods to
community solar and spearheading
community LED smart home research and
installation programs to help families
bring down their energy bills we're even
working directly with elected officials
advocating for more equitable pricing
because to see this vision of energy
equity and resilience succeed we have to
work together sustainably now the u.s.
spends over 3 billion a year on energy
bill payment assistance and these
programs do help millions of people but
they're only able to help a fraction of
those in need in fact there is a forty
seven billion dollar home energy
affordability gap so assistance alone is
not sustainable but by building energy
equity and resilience into our
communities we can ensure a fair and
impartial access to energy that is clean
reliable and affordable at scale micro
grid technology
clean technology and energy efficiency
dramatically improved public health and
for those with high energy burdens it
can help them reclaim 20% of their
income 20 percent of a person's income
who's struggling to make ends meet this
is life-changing this is an opportunity
for families to use their energy savings
to sponsor their future I think back to
my great grandmother and her neighbors
the impossible choices that they had to
make and the effect it had on our whole
community but this is not just about
them there are millions nationwide
having to make the same impossible
choices today and I know high energy
burdens are a tremendous barrier to
overcome but through relationships with
communities in technology we have the
paths to overcome them and when we do we
will all be more resilient thank you
[Applause]
[Music]